il est environ 19 heures hier soir en
baie de fort-de-france
ce hors-bord ramène ses passagers à
celle cher on traverse la rade de fort
de france et tout d'un coup proche de je
dirais un kilomètre à un peu moins de
milles nautiques de la delà de celle
cher il ya eu un gros choc en mai monter
dessus carrément on va dire ça comme ça
je ne comprends pas ce qui s'est passé à
tout tout tout marin tout même
plaisanciers doivent justifier sa
présence sur l'eau par des feux de
position or dans ce cas précis je n'ai
pas vu de faux de feux de position c'est
l'impression d'avoir reçu un coup de
main coup de bâton derrière la tête on
le voit pas venir ce coup de bâton refus
de priorité absence de feux de
navigation
les cinq personnes à bord n'ont pas eu
le temps de réagir notre collègue franck
dolosor qui se tenait à bâbord et
percuté par le taux brisé par l'impact
hémorragie perte de connaissance le
capitaine réagi très vite
suite au choc évidemment la première
chose c'est mettre le navire en sécurité
donc déclenché ces pompes on ne sait pas
si on arrivera docile cas voilà et après
bien sûr appelé le cross qui est qui a
eu après on déclenche et donc les
pompiers pour pouvoir récupérer donc
cette personne ayant un trauma
traumatisme facial accusé de délit de
fuite le capitaine du boston whaler mise
en cause
un plaisancier s'est finalement présenté
aux affaires maritimes se met il fera
bien sûr l'objet de poursuites
judiciaires pour les marins
la formation des plaisanciers n'est pas
suffisante nous on est on est des
professionnels de la mer donc on est
très vigilants
à la navigation et on voit que même en
étant le plus vigilant possible on peut
se retrouver dans des situations
compliquées
woerth ce oui ça arrive mais oui ça
arrive bien sûr puisque en fait si vous
ne faites pas attention ouais je vous
dis un accident est très vite arrivée
on n'est pas sur la terre on est en mer
donc c'est un milieu qu'il faut
respecter et le respect de ce milieu là
un poste de la vigilance à tous azimuts
hier des vies humaines aurait pu être
emportés pour ce professionnel
fortement choqué aujourd'hui la saison
se termine brutalement mettant en péril
son entreprise